all right let's continue with a couple
of other stories that I want to mention
to you the George Soros anti-semitic
media control conspiracy theory is now
coming out
forcefully from the mouth of the failed
former president Donald Trump Trump's
campaign in an email fundraising email
now suggests that George Soros controls
the media this is an email that went out
I believe it's yesterday this is from
Trump asking for money and there's not
even the pretense anymore that they are
doing anything short of just completely
adopting the standard hardcore
right-wing conspiracy theories Trump's
fundraising email rights friend of all
the vile witch hunts and schemes the
radical left Democrats have concocted
since I first came down the golden
escalator this one may truly be the most
despicable because they're not just
trying to silence me
they're trying to cancel out your vote
Soros and his globalist cabal remember
that globalist is often used as a
catch-all for Jews when you can't when
you can't say Jews Soros and his
globalist cabal are attempting to buy
out the media control the airwaves and
guarantee crooked Joe Biden whatever
coverage he desires then they Source a
headline from the Western Journal not
exactly uh the Associated Press which
says Soros group preparing to swoop in
and buy major media company out of
bankruptcy report which
um is a completely different thing from
we're trying to control the media and
give Joe Biden the coverage he wants
this is your standard
generic
anti-semitic conspiracy theory and what
you know people who look at this stuff
closely and have been following it for a
long time as we have you understand that
this is all about
some people just
work in Media
but the Jews
conspire to control the media and that's
the kind of Kernel that's at the heart
of many of these anti-semitic media
control or control banking that's
another one Soros and uh whoever else
they're controlling banking it's not
just oh there are groups that are
different differently represented in
different Industries okay well we could
talk about historical reasons why that
is no big deal great conversation we've
had it many times no it's about the
cabal the globalist cabal Soros and
other Jews you have to understand that
that's what's what's under the surface
here
working together
to their benefit and to the detriment of
everybody else to control the media Etc
so we don't have to spend a lot of time
on this in the sense that I know many of
you already know and understand this
conspiracy theory it doesn't need to be
explained to you and those of you who at
this point insist on denying that that's
what this conspiracy theory is I'm
certainly not going to be able to
convince you but the news is for lack of
a better term Trump now overtly doing
this in fundraising emails